الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تشكك في
الحياد التي تبديه الصين بشان الغزو
الروسي لاوكرانيا بعد اتهام شركات صينيه
بدعم مجموعه فغنر الروسيه وفرض عقوبات
عليها تلقت واشنطن معلومات تفيد بان تدرس
منحى وذخيره لمواصله حربها في اوكرانيا
فسرع وزير خارجيتها الى تحذير كبير
الدبلوماسيين الصينيين على هامش مؤتمر
ميونخ للامن من اتخاذ هذه الخطوه التي من
شانها ان تقود اكثر العلاقات الثنائيه بين
البلدين
راينا حتى الان شركات صينيه تقدم دعما غير
مسلح لروسيا لاستخدامه في اوكرانيا
وبالطبع في الصين لا يوجد فرق بين الشركات
الخاصه والتابعه للدوله قلقنا يستند الى
معلومات تفيد بانهم يفكرون في تقديم دعم
مسلح وقد اوضحنا لهم العواقب الوخيمه التي
قد تترتب على علاقاتنا مقابل الدعم
العسكري لاوكرانيا تحاول الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ردع اي مساعدات ماديه تقدم
لروسيا ايضا من حليفها الصيني الذي زاد من
حجم التبادل التجاري مع موسكو في الاونه
الاخيره الى اكثر من
29% حيث ارتفعت الصادرات الروسيه من الغاز
والنفط والفحم الى الصين فحطمت التبادلات
التجاريه مع موسكو رقما قياسيا العام
الماضي وبلغت 190 مليار دولار في الوقت
التي تحاول فيه الدول الغربيه شل اقتصاد
الروس عبر فرض العقوبات وحاضر الصادرات
توطيد العلاقات الصينيه الروسيه ومحاوله
مساندتها للتهرب من العقوبات المفروضه
عليها يثير غضب واشنطن وفق تاكيدات نائبه
الرئيس الامريكي كما لهاريس